Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P
call any time. 2192. David P. Speaking of
Jorge Santos, here is a caller asking a very
interesting question about the Santos fiasco.
Speaker 5: It is. Jorge Santos was a Democrat.
How do you think the situation would be handled
differently? Do you think that Jeffrey's and the
Democrats would be a lot more proactive in in
the same situation, hypothetically, where you
have a couple seat advantage, the Democrats
have a couple of seat advantage, and it would
hurt their majority and their amount of power.
Speaker 1: I do. Now, you know, this is one of
those things where when I feel that Republicans
and Democrats are basically the same, I will tell
you. And when I think they're different, I will
tell you one of the things that Democrats do to
a fault is they are in their effort to show how
they will not simply stand by any Democrat no
matter what. Sometimes Democrats are too quick
to condemn their own. A great example is the
Al Franken situation. Al Franken involved in a
tasteless joke that was photographed. But what
Al Franken did in retrospect probably was
not worthy of a resignation. And Al Franken
resigned because there was pressure on him to
resign. Anthony Weiner. Democrats abandoned
him. If George Santos were a Democrat, I believe
there is no doubt if he had told these lies and
about these issues that he the pressure on him to
resign would have been total from the Democratic
Party and that he would have ultimately ended up
resigning. Maybe to the detriment of Democrats.
That is the way I have seen Democrats operate
over the last decade in American politics. So
if you disagree with me, let me know. But I think
it would have been handled completely differently
and Sanders would be gone if he were a Democrat
and the same things were uncovered. We have such
a great bonus show for you today.
Speaker 6: Oh, the bonus show,
Yeah. I want to make money. And
everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
On the bonus show today, it has been determined
by a judge that Ron DeSantis violated the First
Amendment by removing an elected official. Who
was that official? I will tell you what. We've
talked about it before. We will take. Talk about
the Jorge Santos drag photos story, because it
is a story about hypocrisy. It's a story about
supposed values that they don't really care about
on the right. It's a very interesting story.
And by the way, I couldn't care less who is a
drag queen. Does it make a difference to me? It's
the hypocrisy that is interesting to me. And we
have a challenger for Kirsten Sinema. Former David
Pakman show guest Ruben Gallego is running against
Kirsten Cinema for Senate in Arizona. We will talk
about what is on the table, what this means for
cinema and for gay ago and much, much more. Sign
up to join Pacman icon. Subscribe to the podcast.
Subscribe to the YouTube channel. Do the thing and
we will see you on the bonus show or back here.